hi guys my name is Jess it is Wednesday
you're watching games with news and
that's everything I have to say before
the intro bus stop South Park the
fraction butthole has been given a
release date again to follow up to
obsidian stick of truth the fractured
but whole is being developed by Ubisoft
San Francisco the game was originally
set to release in December of 2016 but
was delayed until sometime this year
Ubisoft has confirmed a release date of
October 17th and given us a new look at
the game by way of a trailer the trailer
focuses on the fighting vigilante the
players character in the game and you
can check it out in full-on games but
next up over what will be celebrating
its anniversary with a new special event
and a free weekend
well is it have a detailed exactly
what's coming in the next event but it's
safe to assume we can expect new
cosmetic items at the very least the
event will begin on May 23rd and will
coincide with the release of the game of
the year edition the game of the Year
Edition comes with 10 loot boxes as well
as the same bonuses included in the
origins Edition which include 5
character skins a tracer hero for heroes
of the storm a baby Winston pet for
World of Warcraft and Mercy's wings for
Diablo 3 which I'm constantly stunned
people are still playing there will also
be a free weekend for those of you who
haven't yet taken the plunge from May
26th to 29th you'll get access to the
full roster of heroes and maps and any
levels you gain a loot boxes you open
and cosmetic items you equip will carry
over to the full game should you choose
to purchase it afterward heads up you'll
still need PlayStation Plus or Xbox Live
Gold to play on consoles finally you may
have noticed that the new Xbox one and
Windows 10 update out now and here's
what it does Xbox one users will see a
new tournaments tab has been added to
killer instincts game page to add arena
support to the fighting game so you can
now view available tournaments and join
them you can also make your own tourneys
by electing a time and date altering the
settings and writing a description the
latest update is also added looking for
group notifications so you can find out
immediately when someone posts and these
posts can now be shared on act
she feeds through messages Xbox Live
club's will now allow members to filter
broadcast by games and maturity rating
and there's no a tab for being specific
streams which should excite all the beam
fans out there additionally you can now
overlay the names of people in your
party who are speaking and change the
position of the overlay and it's
transparency for the full patch details
head over to our story on GameSpot that
is everything we've got for you today
thanks so much for sticking around at or
is subscribe to us if you like today's
episode and I'll be back with more news
tomorrow